hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one set of issues that st. Augustine is
grappling with in City of God book 11
has to do with what we could call the
metaphysics of creation and this has to
do as well with space and time and he is
pointing out some what in his view are
mistaken understandings of the
relationship between God and the created
world and space and time so he begins by
talking about this biblical passage
coming from Genesis in the beginning God
created the heavens and earth and
there's a really interesting little
disquisition here that that fits in with
his notion of Christian philosophy says
that God made the world we can believe
from no one more safely than from God
himself but where have we heard him from
the Holy Scriptures and then we get this
passage and then he says yeah but was
the Prophet there at the beginning when
God created the heavens on earth this is
a conundrum that people raised and he
says no of course he wasn't but the
Prophet receives this divine wisdom from
God so he says the wisdom of God by whom
all things were made was there and
wisdom insinuates itself and holy souls
makes them the Friends of God in the
prophets and noiselessly informs them of
his works which means that it informs
them with something like an intellectual
communication all right and we can put
that aside for the moment because then
he immediately goes to this conundrum
that is being raised well if God created
the heavens and earth and and that means
that God created the entire world and
indeed the entire universe the cosmos
why did he do it then why did he do it
right then why did God choose that point
in time to create things why didn't he
do it earlier why didn't you do it later
what Augustine is probing here is the
intelligibility of the divine creation
of everything else that is not God he's
saying what's the
and this is indeed a question that
people ask he considers this in the
confessions as well where he makes a
joke about it which you can find in
there but here he considers a few
solutions that in his view aren't really
solution so one one solution is to say
well God didn't create the heavens and
earth all right the world is eternal and
uncreated it's always existed you can
have God if you like it but you know God
didn't actually create the world so
that's that's you know one approach that
you can take and that would answer the
question but Augustine says that one's
not really going to work he says those
who wish to make out that the world is
eternal and without beginning was not
made by God are deceived and Raven the
incurable madness of impiety and he says
how do we know this well we can look at
the world itself and see that it had to
be made by something and it wasn't
auto-generating you could say and this
isn't a very strong argument but it's
the argument that he makes there then he
goes on and he raises another issue and
he's got an another strange sort of
solution to this he says well you could
have a world that is caused by God but
was never created at any moment in time
it never it never came to be it's it has
a creational but not temporal beginning
and this isn't that far away from what
he's actually going to endorse but the
idea is that in a certain way the world
would also be eternal but it would still
stem back to God
and he says this isn't going to work me
provides this rather convoluted argument
about the co eternality of souls and
blessedness and misery and I'm actually
going to skip over that argument because
I don't think it's particularly germane
here if we accept that there is a
temporal creation that is that God
creates the the world in some sense in
time
at a point in time then we can ask this
question well why that point in time why
not earlier if it was a good thing to
create the world why wait around did God
need to sit around and plan it all out
in his head and you know play with some
options or anything like that presumably
not because God is God right I mean we
would do that if we're rational we would
sit down before we build a house and say
what materials am I going to need but
that's that doesn't work for creation so
Augustine says here's where things are
mistaken there is an assumption being
made that there's these eternal gulfs of
time before God creates and why you know
eternal or infinite gulfs of time well
because God is always existed and so
however long it's been and you couldn't
even really say how long it's been
before the creation of the world you've
got an infinite amount of time right and
so why not here why not here why not
here and he says this assumption is
actually wrong and it's similar he says
two assumptions that are being made by
other people for example some of the
Epicureans of the time that are saying
that there's like infinite spaces and
the space that we're in the universe
that we're in is just one within all
these possible spaces or perhaps not
even possible perhaps actual and he says
that they imagine infinite spaces of
time before the world during which God
could not have been idle in like manner
they can conceive outside the world
infinite realms of space which if anyone
says the omnipotent cannot hold his hand
from working will it not follow they
must adopt you Epicurus his dream of
innumerable worlds with this difference
only he asserts they're formed and
destroyed by the fortuitous movements of
atoms and they'll say they're formed by
God's hands so why did God create this
world at this point in time in this spot
Augustine says that's a mistaken way of
looking at it God didn't create it in
this spot
this spot is what he created God didn't
create it at this point in time when
creation occurred that's when time began
so it does have a temporal beginning
creation but it doesn't have a temporal
you could say precedence it
there's no time before it and why is
this the case
well Augustine is saying if we think
about the nature of time what is time
you know we often picture to ourselves
this line that we use with past present
future and we have different ways of
depicting it to ourselves like maybe
we're facing into the future and moving
into it you notice we have to use
spatial metaphors in order to understand
time or we're looking back in memory at
the past and the past doesn't really
exist neither does the future and the
present is just this tiny little sliver
but we depict it through ourselves is
this thing moving forward into the
future all these little moments
comprised right again we spatialize time
as many philosophers have pointed out to
us but how are we doing that how are we
depicting time to ourselves what we
require in order to do that is some sort
of change or movement
we cannot conceptualize and to pick time
without depending on something changing
so you know think about your your watch
if you have one you know think about the
old traditional one with the hands you
watch the hand going around that's
movement or if it's a water clock you
watch the little droplets of water or an
hourglass right we measure time in that
way or Augustine has examples in this
and in the confessions and other places
thinking about syllables how how long is
the word dog right that's a short
syllable now if we're speaking in a
different dialect where it has
massive diphthong Dow right now it's a
longer word and we could use that to
measure things we're doing that
precisely because things are changing
things are remaining the same but also
changing they're going from one state to
another that's how we understand time so
if there isn't anything to change there
is no time so what was God doing before
you know was he twiddling his thumbs was
he thinking to himself and you know sort
of playing with his beard or something
like that before the world began
no God wasn't doing anything when God
decided to create the universe given
this sort of Christian metaphysics the
universe came into being and time and
space both began at that point so it did
have a temporal beginning but not in the
same way that a lot of other people
think where there's time before time
begins or the world begins the world
begins and now at the very same time
that the world begins there is time
meanwhile even using the word meanwhile
doesn't quite fit here right God exists
in an unchanging eternity according to
Augustine so there wasn't any before God
created the world there is God who
exists in a certain sense before the
world right but there's no measure for
that and for God because God exists in
eternity which encompasses all times and
transcends all times at the same time a
little bit of a pun there it's not as if
God has a before and an after himself or
itself or whatever God happens to be so
Augustine here is providing us with a
way of understanding in a very
metaphysical framework what this
scriptural phrase in the beginning God
created the heavens and earth is
supposed to mean
the beginning is literally the beginning
of everything that is not God including
the beginning of space and the beginning
of time
you